I'd like to thank mark of this
opportunity he's a he's a good colleague
and very hard to say no to and I quite
just like giving talks opportunity I
tremendously dislike giving talk so
thank you Marco
Alex described her her work as bridging
work or if she didn't she could have as
part of the privacy tools group she
bridges legal ideas and legal concepts
with these differentially private
algorithmic ideas and theorems when I
joined this project my background is in
applied statistics quantitative social
science statistical software the idea
was I felt we could do some bridging
work to take things that existed that
were coming out of the privacy tools
work and make them practical and the
remit was let's take all these
algorithms that we know how to create
that we know differentially private
let's tweak utility and turn it into the
kinds of things the statisticians would
actually use so what does that mean they
have to have high utility and they have
to understand how to use them correctly
and that seemed like an easy task and my
daughter was born right about the same
time which is really really useful
because she's almost five and that lets
me remember how old she is how long I've
been on this project is how old she is
at any particular time
it has been a long project and it and
this is this is the idea of extracting
utility making things usable both in
terms of having high statistical utility
and answering the kinds of questions
that are of use to two scientists is
really an ongoing research project and
I'm gonna sketch over a bunch of things
I'm going to talk about the system that
we have built some of these these these
things into I think about DP as a
deployable system partly I think I'm
going to re-emphasize things that we've
learned over the last few years which
are the same kinds of things that people
have been saying in all the talks
particularly in the morning sessions
about what did what are the kinds of
issues that that are necessary for real
for real deployment and and this is an
interesting workshop to really focus on
that ok so my background is in is in say
the quantitative social sciences this is
a really nice quote by by Mercy who runs
one of the repositories for I'll talk
about house science repositories open
open open up scientific data for
secondary reuse for replication for
discovery it's really well written but
it's too long so this is the the basic
idea that in the sciences replication is
the foundation if I can't replicate a
result how do I trust it and if I can't
replicate a result then I understand it
well enough maybe to build on it in some
sort of progressive way or reuse that
data to to do something else with it ok
so so the idea of secondary reuse and
replication of data is very central to
the scientific method you have now these
norms that funding agencies expect data
that has been publicly funded to become
publicly accessible we have this
replication crisis in the social
sciences where we don't know which
results might be functions of
methodological flaws or or don't
generalize all this requires you know
this emphasis slightly on replication
and reuse we have these large building
repositories I'll talk about data versus
one but there's a node oh and fixed
share and all these other places where
where data is accumulating in large open
troves unless that data sensitive and
then in that case these repositories
don't know what to do with it
mostly
they've got the data repositories that
where data goes to live for indefinitely
unless the data sensitive and then
repositories where data goes to dying
they get put into locked boxes maybe
there's a process that's very very labor
intensive by which somebody might be
able to get some access to that to that
data but except for larger scale
projects since this is a great working
example but other projects which have
devoted staff to fielding queries about
what data is running running analyses on
the data so that people can discover
whether there are enough observations of
the particular type you need to run the
analysis outside researchers don't
necessarily have the the time or the the
inclination to go through IRB s to get
access to a data and also maybe have to
go through the IRB of the original
collector and get the permission of the
original data owner to find out that
that data actually wasn't the data that
they needed and it was or some other
data in that repository so the goal here
is is how can we facilitate sort of
replication and reuse and discovery of
datasets that are sitting in these
repositories but we can't open up the
raw data because it's sensitive to
researchers through the curator
mechanism through allowing
differentially private releases of
statistics either in some sort of
one-shot release or perhaps through
interactive queries where we trust
researchers enough perhaps to give them
their own budgets we'll talk about about
different we tiered access models has
come up a lot even in Alex's talks we'll
talk about what that might mean here ok
so here's our overview though the goal
of this is is quite different from some
of the applications and deployments that
that we've discussed previously and that
might come up in the rest of the week
I'm teaching a class right now with
Sileo Avedon on trying to investigate
and and and explain to data science
masters students where we're working
through all of the deployments that we
can find general-purpose deployments of
differential privacy and thinking about
how are they coded what are the systems
what are the tasks that they're trying
to accomplish so actually working
through the
actual deployments of differential
privacy some of you might say that's a
really really short class right so um so
please try to make this uh try to make
this a harder class create more of these
things the goal here in this particular
deployment is is that we don't know
ahead of time in a repository setting
and what the next dataset is going to
look like all right we don't have we
don't have somebody tuning algorithms to
very very specific tasks or two very
specific statistical models or two very
specific queries and coming up with a
differentially private algorithm that's
perfectly tuned to that kind of release
don't have the manpower for that don't
have maybe even the technical capability
don't have the scale for that so the
goal here is data sets are constantly
coming into the repository we want some
general-purpose algorithms a general
purpose tool kit that will release
reasonably good summary statistics so
that people can understand and discover
what these data sets are that are
sitting in these boxes when they can't
see the raw data set through a through a
centralized curator model okay so we
want to we wanted to be accessible we
don't want a DP expert in the loop we
just want sort of fine datasets find
algorithms that can be tuned to work
reasonably well across the range of
datasets that we're seeing may general
enough to work across the types of
questions that people are looking at in
these in these socials I say social
sciences but really I should say
sensitive human subjects there sometimes
you know health or or public health data
sets in there also and workflow
embracing so these things are not going
to be used if the scientists who are
coming to discover the data they can't
understand what the results are or can't
access these results outside of the the
statistical toolbox that they've that
they've trained on so how do you work
how do you get things to work within
their own work flow how do you pitch
this in a way that seems additive but
we're not shutting doors to people and
saying you can't have that data but
instead saying there are these data sets
you never would have gotten access to
otherwise here I'm giving you some
access yes it happens to be through a
curated
yes it happens to be noisy but but
making this an additive process and not
a subtractive process we're not taking
data away from researchers we're opening
up data to researchers that they would
otherwise not have any or easy access to
learning about and then this tiered
access model is also a part of our goal
maybe there are settings in which this
might not be the only mechanism by which
people get access to that data so it
could be tiered access here might mean
that when they've discovered the data
set and they're absolutely certain that
it's going to fill their needs maybe
then they do go through an IRB and get
access to the raw data with with the
right privacy protections or maybe there
are researchers who are trying to
discover datasets at different levels of
trust and we're willing to grant
individuals individual Epsilon's so
supposing that we trust them enough to
abide by some data use agreement that we
construct to say you're not going to
collaborate with other researchers to
pull up Salons okay so that's the
overview of what we're trying to do it
is a piece of a the sigh itself is a
piece of an extensive set of tools which
alex has already alluded to so I will
piggyback on that there are a large
number of people who have contributed
this project over the over the past many
seven to eight years now however well
the one thing I will say is so it's
interdisciplinary in the sense that
there are several different centers
there's the there's the Berkman client
center of doing legal reasoning there's
the CS theorists over in the computer
science department
there's the quantitative social
scientists over IQ SS there's Latanya
Sweeney in her in her privacy attack lab
people like Mike over MIT libraries the
main point of this slide is that there
is a lot of white space left and if
people want to join this is this is
please please talk if anything here
intrigues you and you think oh I have
algorithms that I think your system
would use would you like to implement
them for for me or would you like me to
implement them for you please join this
or I have I have use cases for sensitive
data that I think match very very well
the sort of architecture that you're
building here
I'd love for you to consider it please
people come and go not everybody here is
at Harvard but do feel free to visit us
for a year and and if you want to join
this board there's so much space left
okay so some of these tools I'll give a
quick overview of some of the some of
the tools in this in the sort of the
broader system and then I'll concentrate
on one little one of these little arrows
here so in order to make things usable
at a repository level we first need to
understand what's the sensitive data and
what isn't okay so there's a lot of data
in in data verse this repository that
I'll be talking about that is like
astronomical not astronomical is in big
like literally pictures of stars that
size that doesn't require the privacy
preservation maybe differential privacy
still helps for generality okay or but
but doesn't require privacy preservation
so a system a tool system that is able
to extract from the user as they're
depositing their data into this
repository what do you know about your
data what might be the possible
sensitive topics here what are your
ethical obligations to your subjects
what kinds of data use agreements have
you promised your subjects extract that
and understand what's the level of
sensitivity okay so we have this so
here's an example of a series of
interviews that are structured around a
directed graph and then code data sets
into these levels which get embedded
into the metadata of the data set in the
repository in a way that's actionable
from that point on we know the data set
has some some machine actionable set of
policy rules both about security
features and access credentials so so
this is one one product of this system
that might interest you if people do get
access to data sets something that we've
seen a lot of is that the negotiating
terms of use to sensitive data sets when
they are finally going to be made
available can take an awful lot of
manpower particularly lawyerly manpower
so there is a project to try
automate that Claude robot lawyers which
takes in another set of interviews with
the owner of the data and the repository
that it's being stored to understand
what the with the logic rules would be
for processing that data and spit out in
a more automated fashion at data use
agreement
okay so series of logical rules about
what's permitted on the data set can
translate into a license agreement in a
way that expedites that process alex has
already talked about bridging work which
is a central part of this understanding
if we want to get to public access
statistics things that can be released
to the general population that our
summary statistics why that why we can
translate datasets that came in as read
into summary statistics that go out as
AZ level green or level blue that's an
important part of this process but the
thing I want to focus on from this point
on is just this last little arrow here
which is if I have sensitive data how
can i generate public access statistics
summary statistics of the data set for
discovery and possibly summary
statistics that are actually being
generated on the fly by interactive
queries by people who have their own
budgets to ask additional questions of
the system in order to generate these
things so again there's been a lot of
contributors to this system
these are authors on a system level
paper that I'll talk about in a little
bit or I'll point you to at the very
very end including a graduate student
going on the market if anybody's looking
and also a fairly large pool of
developers who have been working on this
both at the repository and and within
the computer science department and also
within UI and UX design so I'll talk a
fair amount on making things usable by
having programmatic and API and GUI
interfaces that direct the user and
constrain their ability to do things
that violate differential privacy when
when composing across a statistical
release and also a large number of
postdocs and visiting fellows and summer
interns and if you want to join this
list please please
talk to me if any of this sounds
interesting to you we have really been
trying to push very recently to make
this increasingly a more community
oriented and less Harvard centric group
and I'll talk a little bit about the
ways the library are expanding and other
universities that have been contributing
and recently especially such as so Sai
it's a named after the ancient Greek
emoticon of somebody shrugging it stands
for private sharing interface it is a
system of four individual tools a
budgeter which which I will guide
through because it's the easiest thing
to demo because it's very graphical that
guides the novice into making reasonable
budgeting decisions about their epsilon
across the statistics that they would
like to release to future researchers
and then a repository that's going to
store that data hopefully in secure ways
an interface for understanding when
these statistics are released well they
come from distributions and they have
they have noise and they have confidence
intervals but those confidence intervals
are two samples and not two populations
so how do you translate all that into a
you know in a reasonably intuitive way
to a non-expert so an interface for that
and then underline this a library of
algorithms silence
presently in our and and we'll talk
about maybe porting that or binding that
to other languages as use cases evolve
this is this is this is our system level
tool I'm going to focus on the budget er
because I think most of the interesting
questions about what makes for a good
system sort of project into decisions
that work created as we tried to build
out this this this sort of usable
privacy interface I said I was going to
talk about the budget er but one page on
the on our library because so this is in
and of itself perhaps the the one thing
that is usable without any of these
other components if you're interested in
a library of functions
it focuses on univariate statistics the
kinds of things that you could imagine
are useful for understanding what a
variable is and for which there's lots
of lots of good algorithms out there
a fair amount of our work has been to
find competing algorithms that exist in
the literature for particular statistics
that we think are of use as summary
statistics and then empirically test
what tends to be the utility of these
things in the scale and types of data
sets you know the data dependent
utilities that you see in the kinds of
data sets that are coming through the
through the through the through the
repositories I'm not saying that the
algorithms that are picked are done in a
data dependent way but you know if there
are clear winners then then that was
that was something - something to learn
often there's a lot of work in the in
the in the literature on obviously on
proving that you meet the utility the
differential privacy definition and it's
hard there to characterize what the
utility might be for these algorithms
and then also basic statistical
estimators so that includes things like
linear regression low dimensional you
know just a couple of co-vary it's a
very simple way to explore data sets can
I predict this outcome as a function of
these one or two variables in a linear
fashion but also things like matching
algorithms if you're interested in
understanding if the person comes to
repository and is interested in learning
causal relationships between variables
treatment and and and control
observations how to match them up to
make nonparametric differences how to do
difference of means tests for causal
inference those basic statistical
estimators some work been we've been
trying to press on on how you do
hypothesis tests how you come up with
confidence intervals for for making
hypothesis tests I mean all this is
continuing to work but this is a focus
of the library because of the focus on
doing open science inference and again
this is this is written in our it's
class-based to make this increasingly
modular so if you have an algorithm
you'd like it might be that component
parts of that algorithm already exists
in our library and we might be able to
implement it by only adding a whatever
your novel twist is if you have things
that you think would work
well in this library do tell us IRA is
raising her hands and Adam is here
somewhere at B you have have have been
working heavily on expanding this
library and bringing in more statistics
so really would like to converse with
people over the next week about anything
they think might might might make sense
to add here so this library is sort of
underlying at the back end again the
data itself in this workflow is going to
this repository data verse data verses
is a federated way a federated
repository for science scientific data
it's an open source platform there's
currently 27 instances of this around
the world 500 institutions have
researchers who with the counts
there's 75,000 social science datasets
in the in the largest of these that's
that's the Harvard repository but you
see that there's a lot of liz' there's a
lot of use of this in in the
quantitative social science community
our tool interfaces with data verse we'd
like to integrate with other
repositories too so that we're not we're
not trying to lock people into this
particular particular setting but
they're across the street so they easy
to work with here's the fundamental
problem is that if I drop data into a
day into into the repository and it has
sensitive data and I declare that it's
gonna get this little locked symbol and
when somebody comes along and says do
you have any data on on whatever the key
word is here this might possibly come up
if it's got a public key words but
there's no way to download or explore or
request access to sensitive data there's
just not the the capacities to do that
so in this in this model we have people
who are who are in our sort of
repository based use case we have a data
depositor who's the owner of the data
and is ethically or legally responsible
for that data we've got a curator who
who's more of a library and say a data
librarian who's charged with archiving
data or in the long run and analysts who
are coming along trying to discover data
sets okay and they they come along with
with different goals that we were
modeling here different levels of trust
these analysts themselves you
might not trust at all or they might
maybe have some like an orchid ID
something that verifies that they're an
academic researcher and and and a unique
individual maybe they're semi trusted
and we're willing to give them a small
budget of their own
okay in this setting then the question
is how do we build how do we build a
layer how do we build a curator - making
it easy for the depositor to explain
what it is they know about their data
and maybe make some choices about
budgeting and similarly allow some
analysts who are semi trusted to also
make queries of this data set okay
and these are the kinds of questions
that we've had to ask and we've been
confronted with trying to trying to
build this out practically in order for
differential privacy to be practical -
to a scientific analyst what are the
kinds of things that they needs
obviously you know this is this is the
groaning question in the room right like
of course they need to be able to
understand what epsilon is so we all
know that but we all kind of want to
punt on that question I realized that it
that people seriously address that but
but that is that is that is something
that is is heavily important to
understand how we interpret Epsilon and
how we set a privacy protection level as
appropriate to different types of
sensitive data how do we explain DP not
in a technical way but in a sort of a
pedagogical way to an applied researcher
how do we express what these errors are
when we're talking about a release
compared to the sample statistics how do
we incorporate that into a measure of
uncertainty if we were doing an
inferential task like a a confidence
interval back to a population how do we
do variable transformations how do we
allow that that's a standard part of
statistical modeling is I've got a data
set I need to make a new variable that's
a function of other variables how do we
test in a way that's provable that if
you want to create a new variable on
this data set before spending any of
your budget that that transform itself
is safe so we have a sort of a haskell
prover for showing that variable
transformations are row by row and then
these models that I talked about earlier
including things like like the bootstrap
or building confidence intervals so
those are changes that those are things
that we've had to emphasize in in in the
research projects of other people in
this in this project but they're not the
only people who answering these
questions by the by say the the DP
community is are not the only people
left to change obviously the analysts
themselves the scientific workflow has
to change in order to use this system
people are trained to first thing you do
open up the data set make sure you
understand what it is look at the raw
values make sure there's columns look
right I'm not going to do that here and
that's very uncomfortable when you're
trying to we've done usage you know use
case studies and and experimental
cassetti's where we bring in researchers
and say okay try and use this this this
curator to answer you to answer this
specific problem on the data set and the
thing that it's really hard to break
them up is okay but first I need to see
the world data to even understand what
this data is that's not going to happen
okay similarly you generally train to
you know if you've got a model there's a
better model if you've got a model how
do you reduce the error in that model
wait you're telling me your system is
going to be adding noise to this model
that's that's you know mind blowing
right these is you know you could be
doubling standard errors by by having a
conservative epsilon obviously some
small effects are going to be drowned
out by that noise obviously this just
runs counter to the idea that there are
sort of purpose of a statistician is to
wring out every single last ounce of
knowledge you might get out of that data
set and you know you're also trained so
how can you write that next clever paper
that reuses data you've already
collected well what's the problem if
epsilon is going to be exhausted and
sometimes you can't go back to that data
set so so these are sort of things you
have to retrain scientists to think
about this similarly there's a lot of
changes for curators there's a lot of
work to put on the repository that
hopefully the you know if the system is
robust it's not too much work but but
lots of system level tasks that you know
we don't normally think of as part of
the differentially private algorithm
like what's the source of randomness
that's being used by this repository
how are we checking for leaking it
leakage how we deal with missing data or
or outlier detection or all these other
pre-processing steps that that we might
not have algorithms for is their
repository doing this are they doing it
in a way this data dependent there might
be leaking information and then
similarly okay so ui/ux testing that's
always important but never more so than
in a system where you can't actually see
the raw data right having a UI system
that makes interacting with data
intuitive even though you can't touch
the data is particularly important here
these are things that that our tool is
focused on again exploratory analysis so
ways of learning what that data set
actually is to learn if that's the data
set perhaps you want to gain access to
and go through the IRB we had some
informal chats with people at IRB and
and particularly with like some
demographers who have a sensitive data
set and they have they have two people
whose entire job is just to field
queries about what their data set is
they have staffers to do that in this
large project and they say about one in
ten pans out
so nine out of ten people are coming
thinking that's their data set in and it
isn't so you know if you can automate
that and and provide access to other
data sets that do not have you know that
level of staffing ability then you would
open up a lot more data and make the
correct matches between researchers and
the data that they're trying to discover
okay I talked about variable
transformations missing data tiered
access let me walk you through the
workflow here actually this is more of a
slide in case my demo fails but
somebody's going to come along they're
going to upload a data set using the
dataverse UI then they're going to make
some that owner is going to make some
decisions about how they want to
partition their epsilon if they're going
to release some summary statistics to
the to the broad world an analyst is
going to come along and discover that
data set then they're going to be able
to read that metadata that's been
released possibly in a in a visual way
or possibly they just read the released
values and if we trust them enough they
can make some additional queries through
this budgeting interface themselves let
me show here that budget orcs there are
live so there are github repositories
for this if you want to play with the
code and there is a
live demo of this that that is up on a
cloud instance that you can look at
whenever you want I'll show you the link
at the end here go to the slides you can
always see this demo but I'm going to
instead play it locally just in case the
Internet
you can get
some people too
okay so the users coming along this is
somebody who owns a data set I'm logged
in I'm going to add a new data set into
the repository so I'm going to enter
some information and some metadata about
it and this is a fairly long process so
I'll skip ahead we do worry a little bit
about exhaustion that is that that users
have to do a lot to upload data in the
first place it's then an extra step to
go through the budgeting process let me
skip ahead just a little bit now what
they're doing as they finally get there
is to say my data is sensitive so you're
going to have to request access this
data cannot be publicly shared with with
with individuals okay so they've just
uploaded their data set I skipped ahead
hopefully to the right point
let's see you still running yeah it is
okay so now I'm now I'm the owner if
I've added the data to the data set I'm
going to maybe I skip too far ahead
let's see what happens this is this is
this is me yesterday
clearly fired okay I'm gonna publish my
data set yes it's going into the
repository now if I switch user and I'm
you know I'm now an outside person
coming along in private modes and I try
to find this California pulls file that
I uploaded and said was sensitive data
even though it isn't it's and I find it
by keywords I'm going to find out that
there's there's nothing that I can share
on this data set there's nothing that I
can read about it okay when I when I
click on it it's not going to have any
ability to understand what's going on in
this it's just it's just completely
locked up and I have to request access
which means ask the original author to
make me an exception so I go back and I
become the owner then I'm going to say
hey let's let's open up some privacy
preserving data previews will give a
brief explanation of what differential
privacy is and if you want to do this
kick it out to this service okay so
you're gonna have to know a little bit
about what differential privacy is in
order to use this as the data owner okay
so we have a few pages that are apps
required reading but as little as we
think you need in order to use the
system effectively here's a little
progress bar you'll see there's there's
actually several pages we're gonna have
to work through one of that was to talk
about what difference where privacy is
now a quick explanation about what these
parameters are and what Upsilon means
and some hypothetical use cases where
some Epsilon's and deltas might be
appropriate for those use cases so I'm
gonna need to make a decision I could
have just possibly clicked one of those
but I'm gonna use epsilon 0.05 and Delta
of 10 to the minus 8 okay believe that
makes sense I think my data matches one
of those use cases in those stories I
need to make some declarations about
what the variable types are the types of
the variables themselves can leak
information even if they're
automatically gleaned
so we need the user to confirm the types
make sense whether or not something is
boolean might reveal whether or not a
third category ever existed in that data
set so types of data can leak
information and I'm gonna need some some
bounds and some ranges some metadata so
I just filled in the ranges for all my
continuous variables in the data set
okay and now I'm going to release some
statistics so I am going to find out
what the statistics are that I can
possibly release on this age variable
you see that it's being explained in the
top and I'm gonna release the mean and I
have all the metadata that I need in
order to run this algorithm and so I'm
being promised that if I release the
mean at my epsilon 0.5 it's going to
give me an error of 0.5 I just asked for
a histogram also it's not adding this to
this to my set of summary statistics yet
because I hadn't filled in all the
metadata so for this algorithm I'm gonna
need to bend the data into 10 bins and
now I have some promises and these
promises can be explained in natural
sentences as I click on each of these
with 95% probability the true mean and
the sample is gonna differ from the mean
that's released by no more than 1.1 9 8
units for the mean for the histogram
there's a different interpretation but
every statistic has a natural language
explanation about what that error
promise is I opened up the epsilon
column we don't necessarily show it to
the user just so that we can see what's
going on here
the epsilon czar being evenly
partitioned across the
I'm generating this is how I'm dealing
with missing values very crude but we
have to do something
so brilliance can be assigned either a
random value or their own category
continuous variables can be drawn from
an interval that the user might might
decide I might want to reserve epsilon
for future queries so I'm using this
slider here let's see what else I've
entered in two of the underlying
parameters here for for approximate for
epsilon Delta it might also be the case
that my data is a random sample of some
larger population and that thing is
secret so here let's say this is some
poems release data let's say we don't
know who these individuals are in their
random sample of 39 million people in
California okay so my epsilon was 0.05
but my functioning epsilon is can be can
be larger than that if I'm willing to
use secrecy of the sample to boost my
functioning Epsilon
and now here's where I'm doing some
budgeting maybe after I've read these
sentences that error seems too large to
me you know mean age that's a variable I
really want to convey to somebody who's
going to use this data so I'm going to
change that error okay and if I want
that promised error then the library is
going to say okay then your epsilon you
need to spend more Epsilon on less
epsilon actually on that particular
statistic I'm adjusting the errors too
to match how important I what I think
are reasonable for these summary
statistics and I'm getting back out
epsilon that compose by advanced
composition to meet those errors and
spend all of the epsilon that I have as
a functioning epsilon that I'm not
reserving for future queries going all
talking a little slower than I want it
to so let me back up but I created a
group of variables that I'm gonna
release a multivariate statistics on
here age sex and marital status and if I
add that into my model now I can release
something like say an OLS regression
might be a statistic so predicts marital
status the metadata that I need on age
in order to create that regression to
bound this this numerical variable was
already in the data set and I'm getting
I'm getting a promise that might not
necessarily be as intuitive as the other
promises
that's a promise on the light on the the
likelihood unfortunately for that as I
said we tried to describe as much
differential privacy as is necessary to
use the interface but no more there are
links to two quick explanations of
differential privacy with built in as as
a manual drawing on a the pedagogical
paper that the group released and Alex
is mentioned earlier at some point I'm
going to decide that's my release and
I'm going to tell this query okay I
think I'm done this action cannot be
undone when I'm okay so I'm fine with
that
I'm gonna release my statistics and now
I am going to take those Epsilon's
across those statistics send it to the
library the library will compute the
releases and write it into metadata and
so here is a who is a quick flash of
that metadata but it's being written
into a JSON format that's much more
extensive it's not just the releases but
it's it's what was the mechanism that
was used what was the error distribution
that's being used what's the standard
deviation on that all being written into
Jason that can be stored into the
repository and now a user can come along
and say now it now there is some
information that they can open up if
there are summary statistics that they
can see that this is a they could look
at the raw JSON file but it's hard to
understand instead they might be able to
visualize it through this through this
visualization tool to Ravens which is a
way of visualizing data through Jason's
without touching data also I can
download those differentially private
statistics and this is what that JSON
format looks like you see that there's a
lot of information in there about about
exactly how that release was generated
okay any questions about the underlying
demo
great and in a few remaining minutes
then let me go back to my slides
okay so usability is really important
here a lot of the work over the last
several years has been on building and
tweaking and trialing and tweaking again
and bringing in user studies and and
tweaking again that interface to try to
make it as intuitive as possible so that
people can basically trigger
differentially private releases without
being experts in privacy it is an
onerous task no matter how fast I try to
explain it but you can see you can
release statistics and a small number of
minutes there is this standard in
usability out there called the system
usability score which is a way of
comparing in some abstract way a certain
set of dimensions of usability across
platforms Excel gets a fifty six point
five point scale on this thing
your GPS probably gets around seventy
where depending upon our version have
been somewhere between your GPS and your
iPhone so we are not as usable as your
iPhone but we are far easier to use than
Excel and and and status and applied
side domain scientists use Excel all the
time so that was sort of like we'll do
better than Excel so this is there's a
paper released in archive if you want to
see more about how we how we been
conducting usability trials what's the
underlying conclusion here we're really
shooting for accessibility that is the
non expert can make differentially
private releases without the
intervention or the use of a statistical
consultant generality that we work we
have algorithms that work pretty well on
the aren't highly tuned aren't the best
necessarily the best algorithm for that
data release but work pretty well on the
next thing coming to the repository
pretty easily incorporated into the
workflow if you already know how to use
data verse so low overhead we think
those things are achievable and this
this this in this and this prototype I'd
like you to go play with it and tell me
what you feel in the near future these
are things what we've trying to do so we
have this library as I said people at bu
are spending a lot spending time
particularly expanding the things that
are in that life
but it has been focused it's been you
know people like people people that we
can hit up to add things to that library
we would love this to be more of a
community driven project if other people
would like to either contribute or guide
implementations or even make suggestions
about things that belong in this library
I'm previewing a little bit's alleles
talk on Friday where I think he'll pitch
some of the future directions that he
would like to open this up to be a more
crowd-sourced more community driven
project than a Harvard project similarly
the architecture itself has been very
sort of specially engineered to work
well with dataverse but we would love to
have sort of community input for what a
what a better vetted architecture that
works and integrates with lots of other
possible deployments or data portals
might look like and how to make an
architecture that's sort of reusable in
other domains we run our code on the day
on the private data because we are
integrated with the repository but we'd
like to we want this year to move this
to a code service model where you come
to Sai as a service and say I would like
to make these releases and side
generates code to make that releases and
then gives it to you in a certified
fashion for you to go run wherever the
data is stored so the data doesn't have
to come to us you know maybe by having
some sort of certified image that that
can be can be run on the data wherever
the data is being held people in
industry don't want to drop their data
into academic repository in order to
allow outsiders access to their data for
example but they might be willing to run
data that's been verified and attested
and certified on their own on their own
systems and then we'd like to you know
work much more heavily on having actual
use cases that demonstrate the utility
of this approach so this is uh this is a
quick preview of what Sylvia wants to
talk about in more detail about
expanding plants and an abrupt and maybe
a reboot
if you're interested in these things
there is this live demo go play with the
budgeting tool and tell me what you're
interested in there's a system-level
paper of Marcos and other people's upon
archive Alex already mentioned this
non-technical primer but it forms a lot
of the underlying manual and way we
explain the system to people by Alex and
and Coby and then these usability
experiments are really quite interesting
how do you make how do you deploy a
system that's actually usable to the non
expert how do you make people who didn't
know differential privacy five minutes
ago able to make it differentially
private release so the issue of
scientific reproducibility is that
something that's come up in the project
I mean the fact that you you're
generating results here but it's hard
for somebody to reproduce them because
of the nature of privacy when you're
signing these so that's why it's
important not only to give point
estimates from from differentially
private releases but to also give you
know some measure of uncertainty about
what that point estimate is and then
think about okay so if I make a release
of a model is the is the model that's
been that's been released previously
possibly on the raw data are these
things congenial are they compatible do
you know is the model that you released
plausible given my confidence interval
for for what that thing might be I think
that's one way of thinking about it and
I think that's why it's it's crucial to
have sort of hypothesis tests the
hypothesis test might not be the null
hypothesis it might just be could could
the thing you have reported have been
have come out of this data set also you
know there are settings in in the sort
of computational Social Sciences where
you know answers aren't deterministic
right so if you got impute missing data
the next time you run that analysis that
analysis is a little bit different so
you know it's not the case that that the
fact or if you're running a you know
money Monte Carlo Markov chain or
something like that you're going to get
some noise so it's not that
you can look over that noise you can
report the noise that you use sure sure
right right right right right yeah yeah
yeah yeah so also there are there are
techniques that people in this room
could talk to you about like
verification strategies where the
differentially private answer you get
back is not the statistics but whether
or not some you know some statistical
model that you believe came out of that
data set is true or not you know where
these variables are statistically
significant yes or no that's a very low
cost answer to get back in a
differentially private way John either
has a question one would like to give a
better answer than I just did either
okay that conversation because I think
it is at the core of one of the issues
that all employers of differential
privacy are facing which is
distinguishing between the replication
exercise the validation exercise on the
comparison exercise M I think that your
system can't expose the entire workload
it doesn't have to expose the random
numbers I think that you could give a
better answer that it is possible to
verify that if the inputs have this
schema this calculation will produce
that number yeah the actual number you
got was drawn from this random
distribution and you actually
highlighted that documenting how you're
drawing random numbers is actually a
very important feature of these so we
have to we have to replication isn't
just if I take this data set of this
code I get this answer that I found in
this paper it's confirming that whole
sold yourself short in that sense that
you do have a good way of exposing the
workload for replication now we need to
talk about validation if I then an
alternative model on a similar data set
how do I calculate discrepancy between
the model levels reduce the first seven
dollars use the second time you need to
be able to release enough information as
well so and so that's partly what I
would expressed is being folded under
reuse or extension or yes is absolutely
public yep and yes that's all the
schemas for the for the through the
releases are schema.org so you can you
know you can take a look at what the
what the jason means and what the
definitions are so we use a open SSL
right now because there are like pretty
clever you know pretty simple attacks
that we realize pretty fast on you know
on other kinds of you know shift
registers that might be might be more
typical sorry oh yes I'm sure I'm sure
lots of people have stumbled onto that
yes yes but you know if you start asking
a lot of queries about things that you
already know the answer to then you can
see the you can you can see the random
number generator and and break it pretty
pretty fast so so having a
cryptographically secure source of
randomization is very crucial and not
going to shock anybody in this room but
but one of those things that you know
isn't necessarily at the forefront of
people's mind in this literature I
suggest we keep some of the discussion
for the
reception afterward when the nursing
certificate academic collaboration of
pipes